let's bring in now ted williams former
dc homicide detective and a criminal and
civil trial attorney and fox news
contributor ted thank you so much for
joining us on this really breaking news
evening what are your thoughts on glenn
maxwell being found guilty of five of
the six federal charges tonight
let me just use the word hooray
let me just say
that delaine maxwell
was a pimp
we need to just call her for what she
was she was pimping these young
innocent girls
for this man
jeffrey epstein who escaped by killing
himself in jail
justice was done what we saw here today
ladies and gentlemen we saw the working
of the criminal justice system we saw
how a jury methodically went over the cr
the evidence and as a result of going
over the evidence they came back and
they convicted this pimp
on five of the six counts against her
the sad commentary and what i would love
to have is that jeffrey epstein would be
here to actually face trial he took the
easy way out and now she's here and what
i'm saying simply is uh as tyrus just
said and i and i hope they throw the
book at her
what we found unfortunately were rich
people
people who could afford just about
anything
going out
using this woman
elaine maxwell as a pimp
to get and pursue these young innocent
girls all for this the appetite of a
sexual predator so
the jury i take my hat off to you all
you all did the right and proper thing
you looked at the evidence you took your
time to go through the evidence and you
came up with these guilty counts and i
am happy i think clearly america can say
that justice justice was done tonight
for these four young women
right ted you know we had a statement
earlier from attorney brad edwards who
represented five dozen of the glean
maxwell jeffrey epstein victims and he
said exactly what you were saying he
said this is the right verdict he said
without her
jeffrey just would have been a sexual
predator without victims on which to
perpetrate his sick crimes he said she
created the monster that hurt so many
people and this jury finally delivered
these victims justice ted leslie
marshall has a question for you
sure in your professional experience
in your professional experience um you
know you talked about her being a pimp i
agree whole-heart-heartedly i also agree
with rotten hell and rot in prison as
well don't be surprised the liberal here
says that but
how likely is it that this will continue
because she the pimp can't do this alone
she the pimp didn't do this alone i mean
she helped jeffrey epstein by going out
and gathering the trust of these young
girls that wolf in sheep's clothing that
she was but there were drivers there
were so many people servants if you will
that worked in his home homes and people
that flew them there are many
individuals that saw what was going on
and kept cashing their paychecks and and
i feel those people are just as guilty
as tyrus said how likely uh that this
net goes larger and wider to get more
and if if possible everyone involved
you know there's always that possibility
because what will happen now at some
stage here
uh
delaney maxwell will be sentenced and if
that say she may very well be able to go
into the prosecutors and make a deal
with them for a reduction in that
sentence by helping to bring the rich
and the powerful
as well as the individuals that you said
there are leslie or
the drivers
of
people who actually saw what was going
on and turned a blind eye to innocent
young kids kids and this is what we're
talking about let's not forget this
we're talking about young girls
and and and the thing about it is while
only four testified and only four were
involved in this trial there are many
others out there
and i'm hoping that as a result of what
we've seen here this guilty verdict that
those individuals will come forward help
prosecutors to bring some of these
sexually deviant individuals to
justice ted williams thank you so much
former dc homicide detective and
attorney your insight was valuable as
always we're so grateful sir thank you
my pleasure hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else